if you believe in this constitutional
republic
equal justice under the law application
of our laws
you ought to be very concerned tonight
and outrage
general flynn's entire life has been put
in limbo for an entire
year for this i've read the entire
report
they even used the logan act and
actually
rarely ever used or invoked
but hillary in the espionage act he's
lost
his house because he couldn't afford the
attorneys he had to sell his house
his life's work 33 years of serving his
country
washed down the drain for this
reputation destroyed for this
nobody in the fbi thought this man lied
comey didn't think so mccabe didn't
think so struck of all people
he didn't think so and he interviewed
lieutenant general flynn
33 years of service five years in combat
in iraq and afghanistan
and this is the treatment this is the
thanks this country gives him
this is what this is how we treat people
what kind of
justice system is this his house nearly
faced bankruptcy
literally and his world crashes before
him and his entire family
and i would bet any amount of money that
the only reason he signed this deal was
well it's the same old system well we
might have to go after your son
work with you and you know then we're
going to invoke the logan act which
nobody invokes to go after him
so he could have made instead of serving
his country
in the private sector a lot more money
but now
he has to sell his house literally fall
on the sword for his family and don't
forget
we got we know that they got through
what
a lot of this information through what
we knew
he was a victim of illegal surveillance
illegal unmasking illegal leaking of raw
intelligence
what about the people involved in those
crimes his rights were
violated at every level now this is a
disgrace and this is what we've been
telling you
is a glaring example of a two-tier
justice system in america
and mueller's sentencing memo says quote
senior government leaders should be held
to the highest standards
uh can we start with hillary clinton and
james comey
because we have a long list of democrats
and trump haters
who have lied under oath before congress
and have faced no consequences for
example longtime
clinton aide cheryl mills uma abedin
lied when they told the fbi
investigators
they had no knowledge of hillary's
private email except they used it
either doj official bruce ohr fusion gps
founder glenn simpson
they of course one of them was lying due
to their contradictory testimony
nobody was held hostage like this for a
year
dirty dossier author christopher steele
his entire dossier's been debunked
he lied to the fbi was fired for lying
to the fbi
but he was still working with the
justice department in bruce ohr to get
to
special counsel mueller james clapper
lied under oath about
national the national surveillance
program so too did john brennan
also likely lying under oath about
leaking and don't forget james comey
himself
lied under oath when he said the report
about the clinton investigation
had not been written before she was
interviewed lie that was being written
in may of 2016. they interviewed her in
july of 2016.
comey's second in command at the fbi
andrew mccabe
fired because of his pathetic pattern of
lying
is he going to end up with something
like this
in his life where are the federal cases
against any of these people
and that's the short list a charge is
going to be brought to all of those
people
when are the screws going to be turned
so they sing or compose
don't hold your breath and according to
michael goodwin president trump
he is now preparing and he should be
preparing for an all-out political war
for good reason
robert mueller and his team of partisan
democrats
even clinton attorneys and a pit bull
that lost 9-0 in the supreme court
cost tens of thousands of people their
job andrew weissman
and put four innocent people once in
jail overturned by the fifth circuit
they have set out to disrupt discredit
and destroy the pres presidency
of donald j trump no matter how many
lives are ruined in the process
you can't get them on the crime let's
get them on a process crime let's set a
perjury trap
now we have a lot more all throughout
the hour we'll check in with congressman
mark meadows and congressman jim jordan
and matt gates also
let this monologue be a warning to
anyone thinking about traveling through
mexico tonight in order to cross the
southern border illegally
a hannity investigation it is not easy
it is not safe
and you are literally risking your life
if we had a wall up and people knew they
could never get in
lives would be saved look at this from
the ap in the past four years
approximately 4 000 migrants
have gone missing four thousand during
their trek through mexico
and the ap is also reporting that the
true number is likely
quote their words much higher and quote
bodies may be lost in the desert and
families may not report missing loved
ones
who were migrating illegally cartels
have a long scary history of kidnapping
enslaving
murdering undocumented migrants
traveling to the u.s
2010 a mass grave containing 72
dead migrants was discovered they were
all murdered by a dangerous
gang cartel called the zetas cartel and
just this year 100 migrants from the
caravan
including children have been kidnapped
that same cartel is purportedly
responsible
for those who successfully do cross the
border illegally
the risks continue even within the
united states as they trek through
rural areas of texas north of the border
hundreds of bodies have been found many
dying of dehydration
after getting lost in the desert in one
texas county alone over 550 bodies have
been recovered
since 2009 we talk about family
separation what about
permanent family separation with people
dying now meanwhile look at this video
fencing along the southern border poses
a serious
risk for illegal immigrants unless we
build a sufficient wall
the shocking video from arizona shows a
suspected smuggler
look at this tossing children over an
18-foot border wall
others below attempting to catch the
kids look at this
on the other side take a look at that
video one as young as two years old
in tijuana where the majority of the 10
000 plus members of the migrant caravan
are
indefinitely stuck in limbo the
conditions there are horrific
they face squalid campsites insufficient
facilities rampant disease a third of
the migrants are now being treated
for health related issues tijuana's
health department is reporting three
confirmed cases of tuberculosis
four cases of hiv and aids four cases of
chickenpox
and a hepatitis outbreak and yesterday
dozens of migrants attempted to sneak
across the border
near tijuana scaling a 10-foot metal
fence that's the one probably chuck
schumer wants
others were able to squeeze through gaps
in the fencing near the coast most were
apprehended
i have no doubt the majority of migrants
headed to the u.s are merely in search
of a better life and more opportunity
that's why if a wall is properly built
it will secure people
on both sides and the door can be built
and we can reform
our our immigration system but be warned
while immigrating into the u.s is legal
illegal and not easy coming across
illegally can take your life through the
southern border
very harsh risky deadly and of course we
often reported the serious consequences
illegal immigration poses to those
already living in the u.s we have a
briefing i witnessed from texas governor
rick perry 642 000 crimes
committed at the hands of illegal
immigrants in a seven-year period in
texas alone
keep in mind every single illegal
immigrant who crosses our border
costs you the taxpayers around 70 grand
and last year's total tax bill was a
whopping 135 billion dollars
a massive border wall would cost just a
fraction of that
and not only would americans literally
give
will we be given important opportunities
here to control our borders but it would
be a deterrent
for people that would take that
treacherous journey through mexico
simple solution to a complex costly
dangerous problem
it's time for the border wall to be
fully funded and right now
we're going to have more on that later
in the show